Now, conditional
probability will
let us explain a lot of
the confused arguments
that people brought
up about Monty Hall.
And we'll see that it is
a little bit confusing
and where there is some
correct sounding arguments that
give you the wrong answer.
So let's go back and
look at our Monty Hall
tree that allowed us to
derive the sample space
and probability space for the
whole process of the prize
being placed and the
contest picking a door
and Carol opening a door.
Now, this tree was
way more complicated
than we needed if all
we were trying to do
was figure out the probability
of winning if you switch.
But having the
tree will allow us
to discuss a whole
bunch of other events
in their probabilities
that will get
us a grip on some of
the arguments that
gave the wrong answer.
So let's look at the
event, first of all
that the goat is at 2.
Now, this is the branch
where the prize is at 2.
And so in all the other
branches the goat is at 2,
l which means that we have
these eight of the 12 outcomes
in the event-- goat is at 2.
Now, let's also look at the
event that the prize is at 1.
That's just this
branch of the tree, OK?
So one of the arguments is
that when the contestant is
at the point where they've seen
that the open door and they're
trying to decide whether
to stick or switch,
they know that the
goat is at the door 2.
Say without loss of
generality that that
was the door that they
got to look at behind,
that Carol opened.
And so we want to ask
the probability, given
that he picked 1, what's the
probability that the prize is
at 1 given that
the goat is at 2?
That means that if
you're at door 1
then you should stick if
that probability is high
and otherwise you
shouldn't stick.
So we can look at this event,
the prize at 1 given the goat
at 2, and what we can see
is that it's taking up
exactly half of the
outcomes for goat at 2
and the same kind of outcomes--
red ones and green ones.
The red ones are worth an
1/18 and the green ones
are worth a 1/9 in
probability, and that
implies that the probability
that the prize is at 1 given
that the goat is at 2 is 1/2.
It really is.
And that's the argument
that people were saying.
They said, look, when
the contestant sees
that the goat is at
door 2, and they're
trying to decide whether
the goat-- the prize is
at the door-- is it door
1 or at the other door,
and it's equally likely.
And so it doesn't matter
whether they stick or switch.
That's a correct
argument but it's not
calculating the probability
of the stick strategy winning.
Why?
Well, because there's
more information that's
available than goat is at 2.
The contestant not only
knows that the goat
is at 2 and trying to
figure out the probability
that the prize is at
1, but the contestant
knows what door he picked.
So let's suppose that the
contestant did pick door 1
and learned that the goat
was at door 2, that's
a different event.
If the blue one is marked
off at the places where
the contestant
picks one, this is
where the door is picked-- is
1 and here's 1 and here's 1.
This 1 splits into one event,
this 1 splits into one event,
but this choice of 1
splits into two outcomes.
And so when we look at the
event that both the goat is at 2
and the contestant
picked 1, which
is what the contest
really knows when they get
to see that there's
a goat at door 2,
we wind up with the overlap
of just three outcomes.
Two outcomes that have
probability 1/8 and one outcome
that has probability a 1/9.
It's just those three.
And the result is that the
probability that the prize is
at 1 given that you
picked 1 and the goat
is at 2-- so this is
the event-- goat at 2
and picked 1, these
three outcomes.
The prize is at 1 is
these two outcomes, which
are each worth an
1/18 and this is
an outcome that's worth a 1/9.
So the prize at
1 outcomes amount
to 1/2 of the total probability
of this event, goat at 2
picked at 1.
So, again, the
probability that the prize
is at 1 given that the
contestant picked 1 and saw
the goat at 2 is a 1/2 also.
That's confusing.
So it seems as though the
contestant may as well stick
because at the point that he
has to decide whether to stick
or switch, and he knows where--
he sees where the goat is
and he knows what
door he's picked,
it's 50-50 whether he
should stick or switch.
The probability that the prize
is at door 1 that he picked
is a 1/2, so it really doesn't
matter if he stays there
or if he decides to switch
to the unopened door.
But wait a minute,
that's not right
because the contestant not
only knows what door he picked,
not only knows that there's
a goat behind a given door
that Carol has opened,
but he knows that Carol
has opened that door.
That's how he got to know
that the goat was there.
So let's go back and
look at the tree.
What basically the
previous two arguments
are conditioning on
the wrong events.
It's a typical mistake
and one that you really
have to watch out for.
So if you use the correct
event, what we're looking at
is the contestant knows
that they've picked door 1.
That's the outcomes of picked
door 1 are marked here.
In addition, the
contestant will get
to know, for example,
in a play of the game
that Carol has opened door 2.
Carol opening door 2 is
quite a different event
from the goat being at 2.
This is a picture of
the outcomes in Carol
opening door 2, and we're
interested in the intersection
of them.
That is, just this
guy that's in both
and this guy that's in both.
There they are.
And so what we
can do is identify
that the event that you
picked 1 and that Carol opened
door 2 consists simply of two
outcomes-- one worth an 1/18
and one worth a 1/9.
Now, of these two outcomes,
which one has the prize at 1?
Well, only that one.
Remember the first component
here is where the prize is.
And so the prize at 1
event among the given
picked 1 and opened 2 is
just this red outcome.
Now, the red outcome
has probability
1/18 and the green
outcome has probability
that's twice as much.
So that means that relative
to this event, the probability
that the prize is at 1 given
that you picked 1 and opened 2
is actually 1/18 over
1/18 plus 1/9, or 1/3.
So given that you picked 1 and
you get to see what Carrol did,
the probability the prize
is at the door you picked
is only 1/3, which means
that if you stick you only
have a 1/3 chance of winning.
You should switch.
And if you do, you'll have a
2/3 probability of winning.
So when we finally condition
on everything that we know,
which is the contestant
knows what door he picked
and what door Carol
opened, then we
discover that it correctly--
as we deduced previously--
that the probability of
switching wins is 2/3.
So we're not trying
to rederive the fact
that the probability of
switching wins is 2/3.
We're trying to illustrate a
very basic blunder that you
have to watch out for, which
is when you're trying to reason
about some situation and
you condition on some event
that you think summarizes
what's going on,
if you don't get the
conditioning event right,
you're going to get
the wrong answer.
So it's easy to see how
many people got confused,
and, in fact, finding the
right event can be tricky.
When in doubt, the 4 step
method with constructing
the tree where you're
not even thinking
about conditional probabilities
but you're just examining
the individual outcomes
is a good fall back
to avoid these kinds of
confusing situations.